if you were suddenly teleported into a
world where dead spirits walked the
earth what would you do these terrifying
ghosts are trying to kill you and
there's no way out of this nightmare i'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
terrifying ghosts in corpse party these
kids have no idea they are all about to
die horrible deaths one day after school
they sit around a dark classroom as this
girl ayumi tells a horrifying story that
happened in this school many years ago
this place was run by headmaster who
treated the school like it was his own
child but after one teacher died falling
down the stairs along with a bunch of
other murders taking place the
headmaster was forced to shut down the
school forever and he went so insane
from it that he threw himself off of the
roof of his own school she also mentions
that their school kisarage academy was
built on top of the very ruins of the
school where all the murders took place
and that the place below them was called
heavenly host elementary school ayumi
then says that the teacher who died
falling down the stairs that her spirit
sometimes wanders these very hallways on
rainy days just like this and this kid
named satoshi freaks the hell out at
this horror story and wants to go home
but the others beg ayami to finish her
horrifying story the rest of these kids
have a death wish they just don't know
it yet then they hear two sinister
knocks coming from the classroom door
just like in ayumi story and the candle
suddenly goes out the door slightly
opens and the class holds their breath
in terror but it turns out he was just
their friendly teacher and this one kid
gets way too excited at the sight of the
teacher the teacher then tells them to
head home but they decide to play one
last friendship game since one of them
is leaving school this girl they decide
to play one last game to make sure they
stay friends forever a game that is
about to change their lives in the most
terrifying way possible the students
then gather and hold this paper charm
cut out and then they all collectively
pull it apart at the same time now as
long as they each keep their piece of
paper their friendship will last forever
and that was their biggest mistake
suddenly the ground violently shakes
causing the school to shudder and amidst
the shaking the whole group is plunged
down into total darkness and that's when
this girl naomi suddenly wakes up in a
creepy looking classroom all alone
shortly after that though she also finds
this girl with her hair looking like she
got two meatballs hanging from each side
of her head we'll call her meatball hair
grow and meatball hair girl says that
maybe they're in some kind of spirit
world and they then both try to figure
out just what in the hell is going on
okay [ __ ] just got real and we literally
have no clue as to how we just got here
what's going on or where we are though
isn't it weirdly suspicious that
meatball hair girl just guessed off the
top of her head that they're in the
spirit world it's kind of suspicious and
random as hell wouldn't you think but
we'll let that slide for now first
things first mindset is half the battle
so it's important that we don't panic
and take things slow because any such
panicking and worrying about stuff is
not going to help us control our
emotions or the major stress hormones
flooding our body because if we let them
take over it will weaken the connections
in our brain and limit the function of
our prefrontal cortex which is the part
of the brain that does all of the
rational information processing by the
way being calm will tell us that if we
remember the earthquake made everyone in
the room go down with us including our
teacher so where are our friends the
first thing that i would do would be to
look around for our friends and our
teacher are they okay is everyone hurt
these are the things that i would check
first i would also make sure that i'm
not hurt myself now if i can't find my
friends or my teacher which does not
make sense because they fell down here
into the same spot where we are so we
should be able to find them or the
remains of them but assuming we can't
find them we can't wait around here
forever though we should wait around for
just a few minutes we did just fall
through a freaking floor that would
cause some loud noise which would make
it very likely that someone nearby or
something would come and find us now if
nothing happens after waiting a few
minutes we should get up and look around
we should also look and see if our own
cell phone works but if our cell phone
doesn't work we should pay attention to
the fact that this place looks like a
school just like ours which means that
this place is bound to have a phone
somewhere and we need to find it because
remember we don't have our friends we
don't have our teacher we're all alone
and we need as much information as we
can in order to get out of here the two
girls try to figure out where they are
as naomi hears a creepy laugh in the
distance but meatball hair girl hears
nothing the two then check out the rest
of this scary place just as this creepy
ass girl stalks them from behind
meatball hair girl then hits the
bathroom before they both head down the
stairs and on the way down there she
gets a little too happy to be alone with
naomi just then they see the front door
and their ticket out of there they also
notice a bunch of little kids shoes
lying everywhere they then wonder if
they are in an elementary school and the
front door seems to be locked just then
now only hears another horrifying laugh
at the distance as meatball hair girl
says that they should spend the night
here until they figure things out the
two then head to the nurse's office to
find some beds and meatball hair girl
helps bandage up irony's foot that
appears to have been hurt during the
fall the two then cuddle up suspiciously
close and prepare to go to bed but
that's when meatball hair girl here
suddenly realizes that she lost her
piece of paper this paper charm that
they all took from earlier thinking she
left it in the bathroom she heads over
there leaving naomi all alone to rest
all of a sudden the lights in the room
go out and naomi finds herself paralyzed
and can't move a muscle suddenly this
book begins scribbling [ __ ] all by
itself and the walls begin to bleed
blood unable to move she is forced to
lay there and watch as the room turns
into a nightmare the air then begins to
change and form into a terrifying spirit
as it terrorizes naomi to the point of
insanity just when she couldn't bear it
any longer she suddenly hears the
screams of being the ball hair girl in
the distance this shocks her and allows
her to break free from the paralyzing
spell and escape the spirit chases after
her but suddenly disappears she suddenly
sees a corpse fall off its chair and
even sees this little girl who smiles
with blood dripping out of her mouth
naomi screams and runs but just then
meatball hair girl returns suddenly
making all of the scariness surrounding
them stop naomi is pissed as hell and
meatball her girl and yells at her for
leaving her behind causing meatball hair
girl to storm off a couple of moments
later naomi then feeling bad for being a
big fat meanie she then hears meatball
hair girl in the bathroom and goes in to
find her but something's not right naomi
then suddenly hears a noise coming from
one of the bathroom stalls slowly
opening the door she finds a nightmare
that she never would have dreamt of in
her most terrifying dreams meatball hair
girl but somehow still alive naomi tries
to save her rushing to find something to
prop up meatball hair girl's feet with
finding this bucket full of nastiness
but that's when the scream stops and not
only comes back to find strands of
meatball hair draping down from a dead
meatball hair girl okay this is insane
and more importantly naomi was too busy
thinking about what a horrible friend
she was to help out poor meatball hair
girl she could have easily saved her at
least for a little while longer if she
acted faster and not just move around
like an idiot but her kicking the bucket
could have happened in one of three ways
the first is based on the actual rope
coming into contact with the area around
the neck where the rope physically
constricts the carotid arteries and
basically stops blood flow from reaching
the brain the second method is by
cervical fracture or by breaking your
neck from a drop but the way meatball
hair girl was squirming means that she
likely died the second way gasping for
breath and her last moments of life
truly a horrific way to have it all end
but what makes me more annoyed was how
useless naomi was because she shouldn't
have even left her side to begin with
much like a kid being put on the
shoulders of a parent naomi should have
done this exact thing as this would have
provided meatball hair girl with a much
more stable platform from which she
could have caught her breath while naomi
figured out an actual plan to get her
down from there now realistically nami
would have to go look for something to
cut her down with and by the looks of
things where the rope is wrapped up
around that wooden beam structure there
seems to be enough clearance up there to
fit a person so firstly i would put
meatball hair girl on my shoulders for a
second let her catch a breath and then i
would tell her if she could climb up
onto that wooden beam with the noose
still attached to her neck and from
there she could rest and this would free
up naomi to go look for something sharp
to cut her down with just then this
glasses girl pops up to a broken-hearted
naomi and she tells her that meatball
hair girl came into contact with the
curse of this place and that she tried
to protect her mind before the curse
could kill her glasses girl then tells
her what's really going on around here
she mentions that a bunch of other kids
from other schools have been sent here
to die just like naomi's class because
the curse of this school drives angry
spirits to kill everyone inside and it
will turn everyone in here dead or alive
that [ __ ] crazy making everybody
eventually kill everybody dead space
style and their souls will eventually be
absorbed by this school elsewhere
satoshi and his little sister sweet
mochida read an old newspaper that they
find which reports on the horrifying
incident that took place here in 1973.
the newspaper reports that after a month
of children disappearing of the case
being closed the police discovered the
corpses of all the missing children
along with this crazy school teacher
behind all of this satoshi then realizes
that this must be the horrifying story
that aimee was telling them at the
beginning and he wonders how they can be
inside heavenly host elementary school
since it was torn down ages ago but this
kid doesn't have time to think because
his sister has to pee so the two set off
to find her a bathroom and to look for
the others they then run into glasses
guy here taking pictures of somebody's
bloody guts on the wall like a creep
glasses guide then tells them that he's
run into other students here from other
schools but no one seems to be in their
right mind and none of them could answer
any of his questions he also mentions
that they are in danger and that he saw
ghosts attacking other students earlier
satoshi then says that they should split
up and look for the others and glasses
guy here agrees to send anybody he finds
to the front entrance of the school
because finding anybody is probably a
good idea in order to increase their
chances of getting back home elsewhere
iom and blonde guy here deal with the
same things that everyone else here is
dealing with absolute madness ayumi
begins to lose her mind just as blonde
guy sees this creepy spirit kid and this
kid is nuts and he charges at them ready
to kill he suddenly pops up near ime to
kill her until he gets distracted by
blond hair guy causing the spirit to
disappear and creepy ass glasses girl
appears out of nowhere again blonde hair
guy asks who the hell she is but glasses
girl just tells him that she's dead and
that she came here to find someone long
ago but suddenly the most insane thing
happens because ayumi here recognizes
glass's girl and they follow her into
the library where ayami tells blonde
hair guy that glasses girl was a famous
high school blogger who wrote all about
ghosts and scary stuff rooted in science
amy then tells glasses girl that she was
a huge fan and that she even got the
friendship charm that everybody else did
earlier from her website the charm that
teleported everyone into this hellhole
blonde hair guy doesn't have time for
any of this in demand to know how they
get back home glasses girl then mentions
that before she died she was researching
this school trying to find a way back
herself and she thinks that the spirits
of the children who died here in 1973 is
what is causing this place to exist
glasses girl says that she doesn't know
how to get back but thinks that if they
find some way to make the spirits happy
they'll let them leave and one way to do
this would be finding out who the
murderer really is and make the killer
repent glasses girl then says that
everybody from iomi's class is here but
that they are all in different
dimensions thanks to this curse
different dimensions but in the same
place kind of like interstellar meaning
that in order to meet the rest of their
friends they'll all have to be within
the same dimension well alright alright
alright alright this is insane and even
though it sounds insane what glasses
girl said in theory could be actually
true because the world as we know it has
three dimensions of space length width
and depth and one dimension of time but
according to the string theory the
universe operates within actually 10
dimensions which include all possible
futures and all possible pasts including
realities with totally different physics
than those in our known universe an
example of this possibly can be seen if
two protons were to be smashed together
at high enough speeds which if this were
to happen in theory their collision
would have the ability to create a tiny
black hole which is so awesome and this
black hole could exist for just a
fraction of a second before disappearing
and that very tiny black hole would open
up a little bubble of interdimensional
space where the laws of physics would
differ this is all still theory but it
goes to show that what we're
experiencing could be actually true and
all of this could explain the certain
things like the weird passage of time
from where we are and why it moves
differently as well as why we can all be
within the same school but not
physically be able to see each other now
with this being said in our minds
completely blown out of the water i
would begin looking to solve this murder
as soon as possible because it's obvious
judging from how crazy everybody is
going we just can't question everybody
we see which means our best bet would be
to work with the most reliable pieces of
information that we have access to and
in this case it would be the school's
library we've seen people in here on and
off reading snippets of past news
articles so it's safe to assume that we
would be able to get the full scoop on
the murders by going through what
actually happened by reading it and the
library is a perfect spot for that by
getting our sherlock on and putting the
pieces together how do i say my good
wanton that we'll be able to keep
ourselves out of harm's way for a little
bit longer glasses girl finishes telling
these two all of this crazy dimension
[ __ ] and she disappears without warning
forcing the two to get moving elsewhere
in another dimension the kid's teacher
walks down this hallway and she reads an
old newspaper about the gruesome deaths
that took place here and reads that the
children who died here died from blood
loss and asphyxiation and had their
tongues cut out as well real gruesome
stuff suddenly she sees a light from
within a room and goes to check it out
and she sees the most terrifying thing
one of her students talking with two of
the murdered kids and this little girl
says that she's not leaving that she
needs to be there for the children the
teacher tells her to snap out of it
suddenly causing these two children to
freak out and yank the little girl up
into the air and ride out this window
grinding her body into mincemeat down
the hallway smacking her into a wall
leaving nothing but her little hair tie
to show for it the teacher looks on in
sheer horror as she is brutally crushed
by this guy in some other part of the
school glasses guy takes a break finding
his classmates and he sits down to look
at the pictures from within his phone
and he wonders where his friend this
little girl is he begins to smile and
takes a moment to enjoy his sick fetish
looking at the mutilated corpses of the
school's past victims as he goes through
his phone he finds one which excites him
more than all the rest but he just then
gets a call from the dead girl in his
photo which makes him realize who he's
really looking at his beloved classmate
elsewhere satoshi continues to look for
a bathroom for his sister as they run
into this creepy girl and she leads them
to what they think is sweet mochita's
potty salvation guiding them through
these doors and out into this walkway
but sweet mochita can't wait any longer
so he tells his sister to go do her
thang near the trees in the distance but
don't go too far taking little red dress
girl along with her satoshi then finds
an id on the floor belonging to another
student with the same piece of paper as
everyone else has looks like everyone
else performed the same ritual as them
to get here and he then heads inside to
wait okay this is crazy this is probably
the most insane thing ever and we've
have yet to address the elephant in the
room and that elephant's name is
freaking satoshi idiot like what are you
doing you just freaking teleported into
a literal nightmare with ghosts out to
kill you and you have no weapons you
have no help you're all alone and you
think it's a good idea to leave your
sister alone i don't care if she's with
that little demon child that's even
worse leaving two kids alone in a
strange place are you nuts and to top it
off that little girl is probably a
psychotic ghost like what are you doing
satoshi played it so dumb it is
mind-numbing how idiotic that move is
you already split up from glasses guy
and now you want to split up again with
your sister even temporarily if satoshi
had any sense he would have told her to
just do it in a corner with his back
turn so at least he can make sure that
nothing happens to her inside satoshi
hears the horrifying screams of his
little sister but the door won't budge
and he turns around to see little red
dress girl sweet mochita bust through
the door to find her brother gone
leaving her all alone back with ayumi
and blonde guy they walk down the halls
and they talk about the doll that they
found and they think that it belongs to
the killer of all of these kids suddenly
the doll starts talking blonde hair guy
freaks out and trips and falls through
this wall finding this bloody pouch the
doll continues talking repenting for all
of the murders and pain it caused to
those children which makes aimee suspect
that this little doll is in fact the
killer himself blond-haired guy gives
the bloodied pouch to iomi who finds a
name on it that she thinks belonged to
one of the dead children blonde hair guy
then realizes that the name belongs to
the same kid who attacked them earlier
just as that kid shows up and demands
that they give it back the kid goes into
full-on rage mode and attacks ayami
until she quickly shoves the tongue into
the kid's face and he suddenly stops
being evil and smiles and gets sent to
heaven the two then realized that they
just gave back what the murderer stole
from that dead kid meaning there's only
three spirits left to be set free iomi
and blonde hair guide then continue to
find the rest of the tongues belonging
to the other dead kids and with some
digging they find almost all of the
tongues except one something isn't right
because the last kid according to the
news article was found before she died
aimee suspects that they won't be able
to set the last spirit free the same way
as they did for the others but blonde
guy thinks that if she didn't die that
there's no need for her to be set free
aimee then mentions that if this was the
case then everything should have already
gone back to normal by now but it hasn't
forcing aimee to think harder about
what's really going on elsewhere
terrified mochita roams the halls as she
looks for her brother and she runs into
good old glasses sky but something isn't
right about him and she can tell and
glasses guy reveals himself to be on
some serious creepo and charges at her
and sweet mochita runs for her life she
hides in sheer horror but suddenly is
found by this guy mr stud face and he
lures sweet mochita out telling her that
he's also looking for his little sister
but just then glasses guy finds them but
mr stud face moves as good as he looks
and kills glasses guys straight into his
windpipe mr studface turns around to
mochita revealing that he too is bat
[ __ ] crazy calling sweet mochida his new
sister mochida runs for her life and she
is led to safety by little red dress
girl suddenly a massive earthquake rips
through everybody just like in the
beginning and luckily for iomi and
blonde guy the earthquake sends them all
the way back to where it all began their
original school back in the spirit realm
satoshi isn't as lucky and he continues
to explore this place instead of trying
to find his sister what a jerk and he
sees from this newspaper that only one
girl survived those murders all those
years ago and the person who survived
looks exactly like little red dress girl
but if she's alive then why is she in
this hell hole with all of them he then
finds a tape nearby with a recent date
on it and this book that he thinks he
could use to send everybody back home
suddenly glasses girl pops up and tells
them that they all messed up the ritual
that they did at the beginning and she
doctor strange's his horny ass to the
person he's thinking of most in that
moment back in the land of the living
these two have no clue what's going on
just as this portal opens up and one of
the main murdered girls appears and
mentions that if they want to save their
friends they'll have to do more than
just return all of the tongues to the
kids they need to help the spirits find
peace and she then shows them exactly
how she was brutally murdered so they
know what kind of terror they all
experienced by literally putting iomi
into this dead girl's shoes replaying
the night that she was brutally murdered
and aimee finds out who the real killer
is little red dress girl and we find out
that she ordered the murders of all of
these children and basically bossed
around this big guy into helping her
commit these crimes iomi then wakes back
up with a fright and decides to go back
into the spirit realm to help her
friends but blonde dude wusses out and
the dead girl tells her to hurry because
the souls of the heavenly host
elementary school have begun looking for
a new host and soon even the good
spirits like this girl will go insane so
with the clock ticking ime is then
teleported back into the spirit realm to
stop all of this this is a casebook
example of when you go to the spirit
realm folks who don't trust anybody
including tiny little girls little red
dress girl is nuts and to be honest i
wouldn't trust her with my life in fact
a blonde hair guy here is the only one
thinking smart about this and is
actually using his brain does that make
him a worse still however yes yes it
does but that's okay he's a smart wuss
and let's be honest at most any of these
kids are about 10 years or younger maybe
blonde hair guys 13 max and that's the
thing how precious is any kid
relationship you've ever had that you
must risk your life for on average by
the time you graduate and become a big
boy you lose half of those relationships
just like that which means more likely
than not if all of these kids somehow
survive they'll all lose touch with each
other eventually which means they
wouldn't even be in our lives after a
certain point which means they might as
well be dead to begin with see what i
did there i brought that logic back full
circle if the tree falls in the forest
when no one is around does it make a
sound i say no no it doesn't and so even
if we went back to save all of our
friends right now we'd lose touch with
them eventually which means we might as
well speed up the process of us not
knowing them sooner and leave them to
die right now quoting sun tzu the art of
war elsewhere a given up naomi lays down
defeated thanks to meatball hair girl's
death earlier and just then good old
horn dog satoshi appears near her thanks
to glasses girl and she hugs the crap
out of him and this dude totally doesn't
feel bad about it at all even though he
probably should have thought of his
sister instead and glasses girl totally
gave him the chance too she then tells
satoshi that meatball hair girl died and
takes him to her corpse but he thinks
something is suspicious and that maybe
the spirits made her die because
meatball hair girl wouldn't just die
like that which means they can't trust
anything in here meanwhile back with
sweet mochida she finally escapes from
mr stud face but that's when red dress
girl turns full nutso and prepares to
kill her forcing sweet mojito to yet
again run for her life ending up in this
room but that's when she turns around
and sees her worst nightmare it's mr
stud face looking like a bloodied
possessed anatomy mannequin that you'd
find in medical school he grabs
mochita's sweet face and ties her up he
then brutally torches her doing the most
despicable things to mochita he even
scoops out her eyeball ben and jerry's
style forcing her to squeal like a
gutted pig but he doesn't stop and
slowly plunges his knife into her chest
just as blond hair guy comes in swinging
slicing mr stud face's head off but it's
too late blonde hair guy does try to
save her but then this big dude comes at
him and they fight imei then arrives and
tries to get sweet mochida out of there
but then she turns around and sees
blonde hair guy covered in blood he came
back to save them all and that was his
biggest mistake suddenly he gets stabbed
through the stomach blood spilling
everywhere and he tells them with his
last breath to run then suddenly a hand
forces its way through his mouth nothing
can stop this dude and ayumi and sweet
mochida look in sheer terror satoshi
then arrives late as balls thanks to
sweet mochida screams from earlier and
saves the two taking them back to naomi
this is madness and blonde hair guy
kinda did move up in my book with that
superhero save there but here's the
thing why did he simultaneously feel the
need to become the biggest idiot in this
side of the western hemisphere sweet
mochi that was pretty much already dead
to begin with let's be honest she was a
liability from the start and i'm amazed
that she made it this far but she was
dead weight all along the fact is you
saw it clearly too everyone was too late
to save her and sweet mochi the sweet
face was destined to get royally screwed
up since birth if anything blonde hair
guy should have sliced mr stud face and
then in an act of pure mercy killing i'm
sure plunged the dagger into sweet
mochida's neck causing her to bleed out
fast see what i mean mercy killing
because by the time he showed up she was
pretty much already dead cut up on that
tortured table in fact if he just put
her out of her misery like a true hero
then he could have spared her last
moments of pure terror and agony and he
could have still been alive to help us
on our journey getting out of here
because if you're asking me to choose
between a badass dude or a six-year-old
girl who is dumb as a fugu fish is
deadly then it's no competition i'm
choosing the blonde badass cause sweet
mochita is certifiably useless and while
we're on that note why did blonde hair
guy feel the need to come at the zombie
spirit dude there's weight classes in
physical sports for a reason folks just
from his stature alone i could have told
you from a distance that that zombie
spirit dude is well over six feet and is
not to be messed with because one-on-one
it's highly unlikely that a high
schooler would have been able to take
him on blonde dude risked his life to
save a six-year-old girl come on they
should have been most try to attack him
from a distance only to keep him at bay
while they try to get the hell out of
there moral of the story folks don't
save the kids satoshi then sits outside
with the sister that he failed to save
like a loser and the group watches and
waits as sweet mochida sweetness ends in
bitter tears for the rest of the group
later on the gang forgets about the
sister anime style quick and recap what
they know they talk about how little red
dress girl is the true evil around here
and they discuss that the only way to
make it back home is by putting all the
spirits to rest which means they gotta
do one thing get a confession from the
killer but to do all of this they need
their charms from earlier but naomi like
a dumb booboo is missing hers needlessly
complicating everything the group then
decides to go search the school one last
time for their teacher and aimee then
has the sudden realization that the
notebook satoshi found earlier belongs
to glasses girl which if this is true
means that everything on her blog is a
lie and that's when she runs into
glasses girl who turns out to be batshit
nutso 2 and confirms what ayumi is
thinking glasses girl reveals that her
online blog was a trap designed to make
more people come here and investigate
the murders that happened here and in
doing so sucking more people into this
curse and taking their souls and she
claims that she did all of this out of
love for a guy that she met here ages
back this is the someone she was looking
for as a spirit all this while ayami
then reveals to glasses girl what she
really did to her one true love and says
that this place possessed her to kill
her man showing glass's girl her and her
lover's corpse causing glasses girl to
vomit out black sludge and releasing her
spirit into the afterlife once and for
all elsewhere satoshi and naomi find out
thanks to this conveniently placed book
my look at that that little red dress
girl is trapping all of these souls here
in order to provide the spirit of her
dead mother with company and they
realize that this book is the diary of
little red dress girl's mother they also
find out that this mother is the same
person who died falling down the stairs
of this school all those years ago this
is what caused little red dress girl to
go crazy in the afterlife trapping her
spirit and all of the others who died in
this place the two then find a room with
seals everywhere and that's when satoshi
is suddenly hit with a supernatural
flashback seeing the principle of this
school cutting out little red dress
girl's tongue and stabbing her body but
the flashback suddenly stops as another
earthquake rumble happens breaking off
this wall and revealing a ladder causing
the two kids to head down further into
the devil's steps as they come across
this terrifying torture room they then
hear footsteps coming and they quickly
hide under the table and they see this
dude drop a meatball girl's corpse and
he then cuts out her tongue the two kids
look in horror and naomi loses her mind
and runs after meatball hair girl's
corpse satoshi chases after her but
cannot find her oh my gosh that was
sickening also naomi's gotta cool her
jets like whoa settle down captain
marvel we don't know who this this
monster is and what is she going to do
she's just going to run around willy
nilly bad plan
satoshi shouldn't have even bothered
chasing after her and should have stayed
hidden because have you guys played out
last i have this is the exact same type
of [ __ ] that would have had the monsters
pretend to leave the area only to sneak
attack us from behind nope no thanks not
gonna do that if we were to go look for
her we should look around the room and
see if there's anything that we could
use to defend ourselves there's a lot of
chains hanging can we take those down
there also seems to be some tools and
instruments of torture in the back
corner of the room on that table we
should also check the closet over there
and see what's inside it once we've
armed ourselves with whatever we can
find we should cover our scent of life
what i mean by that is these ghosts
attacking us are dead and some of them
seem to have varying degrees of
intelligence and clarity of thought it
makes me wonder if we were to drench
ourselves with the blood of these
victims cover ourselves in all the
tonguey gore that we can and appear to
be dead i believe that it is possible
that we could mask our scent of being
alive i would have preferred to test out
this theory beforehand on someone else
but we're out of options here we need to
maximize our chances of survival as we
wander these haunted tunnels looking for
our friend who abandoned us underneath
this cursed school thanks to the
earthquake from earlier ayumi sits in a
bunch of rubble and is confused as hell
she then sees a bunch more scary [ __ ]
just as satoshi shows up and tells aimee
that everyone else from their class aka
all the c plot characters that she found
are dead and that's when this nice
spirit shows up again and tells these
two that naomi is now under control by
the curse of this place and that she'll
need to overcome its powers before
returning back to them and while they
wait they head off and finally find the
corpse of little red dress girl laying
right next to the psycho killer
headmaster and that's when the vengeful
spirit of little red dress girl comes at
them for blood stabbing satoshi's right
hand as her good half also shows up to
the corpse party elsewhere as naomi
continues to fight her own demons this
haunted place reveals to her the most
insane thing ever it reveals to her that
it was actually her who killed meatball
hair girl this place possessed her to do
it causing her to lose her mind but in
all this sadness meatball hair growth
caused naomi from beyond the grave to
forgive her and she finally breaks free
from the curse back at this corpse party
satoshi sits cut to [ __ ] and tries to
talk some sense into both the good half
and the bad half of the ghost of little
red dress girl and desperately tells her
that her and her mother were the first
victims of all of this and we see a
flashback of the headmaster accidentally
pushing her mother down the stairs and
little redress girl sees it all this is
how she died and what caused all of this
satoshi then hands the good spirit her
tongue that he found earlier and finally
sets the two in one spirits free but
suddenly the whole school starts
crumbling and this ghost girl pops up
again and tells everyone that they need
to get out of here now gathering the
three outside to perform the same ritual
that brought them here but because naomi
lost her charm earlier like a dope
satoshi then offers his own charm for
her to use lending her his helping hand
and mentions that he'll just use his
sister's charm that he held onto for his
sister but turns out this kiddo lent out
one too many hands and comes up short
because when they teleport back to their
original school the two girls look in
sheer horror with each of them holding
one of satoshi's bloodied arms causing
the duo to sit at the proverbial finish
line in dead silence bummer but what do
you think about corp's party let us know
what you liked and what you didn't like
about the video and as always don't
forget to leave a thumbs up and don't
forget to check out our how to be
playlist